we really want to work as a community
together to be able to combat this
outbreak as it's happening
my lab had been working in Sierra Leone
and Nigeria for a very long time working
on another virus called Lassa virus
that's similar in that it causes
hemorrhagic fever like Ebola and when
the outbreak began in West Africa we
helped our teams their setup diagnosis
and surveillance on ground I was
involved in the diagnosis of the first
Ebola case in Nigeria and the reason why
we were ready with the with the tools
and in the region for diagnosing Ebola
is because to my collaborators at
Harvard I was involved I'm involved in
the work that is going on in certain
Leone and when this particular patient
presented with clinical signs symptoms
similar to Ebola and the sample was
collected naturally the turn of sending
the sample to our labs resequenced 99
samples from 78 patients that were the
first patients diagnosed in Sierra Leone
as part of the Ebola outbreak and in
fact we captured 94 percent of patients
diagnosed in Sierra Leone in the first
three weeks of the infection and the
kinds of things that we could figure out
from it is we could we could see that if
you look at the three published Ghanaian
strains that these are all linked these
are all appear to be one chain of events
and particularly we can really have a
close view of what happened in Sierra
Leone and it seems like there was one
entry into Sierra Leone that then spread
throughout we see hundreds of mutations
over 300 mutations that separate this
virus from past viruses we see about 55
mutations that have just happened within
the course of this outbreak event and we
also see hundreds of mutations that are
happening within individuals things that
may one day become common in the
population and fixed between individuals
many of those are functional so we're
going to be paying attention to those
this is providing information life and
for people that are interested in work
from work developing either drugs or
vaccines or having understanding of
pathogenesis that actually provide I
mean crucial information for them to go
on and then develop whatever tools a lot
of the Diagnostics are built on the
genome sequence of the virus itself so
we can say which ones are would still be
sensitive and which ones the virus is
sort of mutated away from same thing
with vaccines vaccines are built on the
approach
sequence which are themselves built on
the genome sequence so we can see if
that's changing there are certain
important proteins that are critical to
that and as well with with the drugs as
well
so it's the type of genome sequencing we
do informs whether or not the drugs the
vaccines the diagnostics that we're
using are going to be viable as the
virus continues to mutate and change
you